hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play enviro bear mm
now I know you're well you're saying
you're pressing another bear driving
similarly I know I know you got your
bear Turismo your bears uh your need for
bear slammin salmon edition but do you
know I I don't think that those all
capture the emotional aspect of what it
is to be a bear when you're trying to
get ready for hibernation so the
objective is eat fish and berries to
fatten up and winter arrives in five
minutes so it's like oh it's like the
adrenaline rush you'd get from those
triple a bear driving titles but you
know you're really really connect with
like imagine what it is like to be the
bear so here we go okay yeah ah Oh what
the hell
look that's those convenient I've got
the tail to tail care go to ice you're a
fish Duff stop flopping around oh hey oh
no oh I can every day now Oh got my fill
full bear oh my it was that the cave
over there I think I see the cave oh ah
see the gripping graphics are really
what tie this whole this whole
experience together I mean it's all
about you know really really really
getting nailing the mechanics of bear
driving ah yeah hibernation you're - you
feel famished why do I keep waking up
five minutes before winter arrives
alright that year was easy
I'm pretty good pretty good let's see a
lake over there let's go in that
direction whoo ah whoo ah ah I see I got
some competition
whoa oh there's another lake over here
right by the cave so what happened I
think didn't last time I just drove over
it and fish fell in my car is it not
gonna be that easy this time damn it how
the hell am I do this ya know the tree
oh damn it what ah leaves my car da got
this like difficult it's difficult it's
not easy as it should be truly the
struggle of the Bears fully encompassed
in this game right now I keep running it
oh wait is up is that a berry bush
I see red dots on that maybe that one's
got berries Graham it
oh yes berries gimme gimme berries yeah
yes fatten up for winter hi cut out of
here competition bear I will Ram your
ass off of road uh it's a
no-holds-barred bear competition out
here oh don't tell me this isn't gonna
be enough I gotta write down sorry I'm
trying bear
I'm trying stop being angry oh okay
no-go need to find more beautifly all
you want some you want that back yeah
that's right run off huh I don't know
where I got the salmon I thought it was
from the lake I guess I was wrong oh
good I got his crap in my car
ha ha tray punch pine cones can eat
those hey can I eat no I don't oh wait
no no damn it I thought maybe uh huh I
see salmon go for it go bear no get away
from my salmon get a bit of my salmon ok
yes ah must each time bottled up oh my
god you dick where my where my other
fish go I'm not oh no you did it
I've got this so much crap here I can't
press down the pedal
ah now don't have that tray damn it
good back now Steve fish Marty fish not
much time left
bear hey fish it's a smorgasbord
I know the cave is right here so that
when I fat enough I'm gonna get there
oh wait no my gas meter told me when I
was I see it man it would have taken up
millions berries to get their coal ha ha
I got a pop in a reverse here what's up
oh hey whoa what happened guy turn
around what happened I got bones all
over my I'd go for that one ah
come on
I know I know I'm still eating come on
Oh God come up come on come on come on
hug I'm gonna be inundated with salmon
ha ha ha year two done with skill full
moon the Badgers are restless okay click
to drive I wish I had two hands
this would be nice hand ah yeah yes oh
this is gonna be much easier god I'm a
I'm Oh God
ah ha skills well are you are you a bear
I can't tell are you one of those wombat
I've heard so much about dammit dammit
nah gonna pop in Reverse Oh
get those berries here's a berries damn
it I'm gonna drive why won't you go to
drive by watching Ontario
there's an armored vehicle is demanding
Oh what good on that damn put up buggy
pinecone there we go ah no I just tossed
the berries everywhere give me the
berries I've run a brine bear hey Barry
do nothing for me
hey Barry they do nothing got that Barry
got Barry uh-huh over warm up air dry
okay huh yeah where's the lake
where's I like Derek the lake I see the
salmon there's so tasty looking get back
here clock come on ha ha ha
cover cover depth you then I'll do
it manually I don't need you of tree not
see ya trick ya know I don't leaves in
here now I'm like balls Bob Merrick oh
there's more legs over there oh oh
off
ah that clock wasn't reliable anyway
Jimmy coming up and then oh yeah and
stop the car so that was it I'm gonna
win this game
ha get over here I'm gonna make my
ancestors proud of me huh stop flopping
around in a boy first you can't escape
your fate huh okay turn left and
ah boss first stop no stop
Oh Rach no get out of here Rach I don't
need a rock
I'll wait no this something right in
front me all right bra rule
okay this is not enough not enough I
need to find another one these are gonna
be not no oh my god there's so much crap
in my car no no no that's right Wow know
where to go where to go where to go
where did that damn it was you right
here all of my everything ha ha
this games hard huh
this game is hard like all the hardcore
bare driving fans out there I mean you
really do want to challenge when you get
these games I mean it's not fun if this
was easy
what the hell what good my hair there
decided to take on the Elvis look oh oh
no fish in that Lake I suppose we all
missed it I'll face it I like no screw
you buddy and my fish and my fish
yeah my fish oh one one one can I get
rid of these yeah I think I did I think
I threw it out the window or something
yeah here others bear wombat I don't
know what you are oh not that trick dog
wasps bees I don't know I might lose
this one not a rock ah balls hey her
little buggers little buggers are
everywhere
good I'm not gonna make it oh my
goodness
sorry the big fish tail - it's a tail a
tail go around just let's get the other
fish let's get the other not you big guy
oh god oh god oh god damn it come make
me drop everything you son of a
Gandhi I'm trying I'm trying bear
something's on my gas pedal no all right
stop I got Little Rock's fish bees
everything get off ah no no like oh yeah
got my car
oh honey okay there we go oh man this is
intense ha man I couldn't ask for more
in a bear driving simulator ha this is
the greatest ever what an adrenaline
rush I can't believe it I don't eat
berries I need you a hybrid a I'm gonna
win humming a win
know what happened now don't this
up for me bear you dick dire huh gut
stop reverse turn backwards backwards
stop drive left drive not into the tray
okay oh god I cannot lose this now I
would go to win what the hell happened
in the last two minutes
geez change the lease give me the
freakin cave stop drive go turn huh this
is the most intense game I ever played
I feel so emotionally connected to this
bear driving simulator I must continue
Oh No will my skill tells out what is
wrong with my neck something is very
wrong
well my skills as a bear cub evolved to
the point where cowboy lets you're like
huh
ah my bears cannot B's right off the bat
hey ah huh
nope come in Wow no I said ah
my toss my gosh my fish right out the
window
I might not get this one going am I not
this might be the end of this bear sadly
to say the end of all bear driving
simulators the cycle that it represents
life and death so carefully balanced in
an intense dance of nature oh well my
next shaped out a bit looks like I just
needed a fat enough of it what'd ya hear
pine cones the birth of life shall not
burst forth within my car
I'm getting all existential on the I'm
just feel so emotionally connected with
this game this is what this is what's
missing in bear Turismo
I mean bear Turismo I mean come on there
are a lot of professional bear drivers I
understand that I understand that bear
driving as a sport you know even though
I don't watch it it's very important to
a lot of people but come on
you really need to quipping the gripping
reality that bear driving can bring you
berries oh no that's sad to say this
might be the end of the line for us
no I got robbed not bad good magic give
me your insurance information I require
man whoo hi I'm almost out of time I see
the clock it's ticking down on my life
and sadly the story of this bear is
coming to a close maybe not whoa maybe
not maybe not maybe not Cave is right
there so much food right here in my face
so much food Oh give me the food give me
the food oh oh my
maybe I have a chance baby maybe our
chance
oh man Oh down to the wire the Dilla
little story of my life is not yet over
hi every night got away Oh
and right there my maggot burn how did I
win that oh this is the greatest let's
play I've ever done in my entire life
I'll tell you what this is that I've
never felt more of an adrenaline rush
the intensity the the drive the
incredible feeling of nature the graphic
sir astonishing
Jimmy stop for a break
well I'm on Steve Brown I'm getting good
at this actually let me some berries
stop to eat these huh yeah huh girl give
me that I don't know you don't do much
for me but there's some hey who's gonna
hit me I heard another car know there's
a berry berry world
chop-chop I'm trotting good job I'll try
to get it it's your hands throw it your
hands what happened to the fish that I
was just driving there
another berrygood more sustenance for
Barry the bear Boosh tell me the fish
shall stop here
so far I've only got a food yeah this is
good is a good sign but still it's not
enough not enough 4-barrel the bear must
keep eating the sustain I'm so close you
could see my belly's getting a better
pour you want some you want some
Oh what that ha oh no oh no I was doing
so good
no no no no no no no no lose control
their little is go drill them don't get
over the break
oh oh come on oh come on oh come on Bob
bollocks balls I keep hitting everything
they keep hitting everything
Jimmy Oh big fish Chuck come on son come
on there we go there we go all right
Oh God yeah boy go away I don't have
time I don't know I'll better make this
gone from god damn it get out from under
get oh my god no it can't end like this
the can't end like this it can't it
can't Jesus get out of here
it can't end like this it can't
no no where's it there let's go oh stop
oh stop stop stop stop stop stop you
have the brake go stop stop backing up
no no
stop get out oh do not mess this up for
me
do not mess this up for me this is the
greatest game I've ever played there's
the greatest game ever
I am the bear champion yeah I am the
bear no no I can't fatten up on berries
alone it's impossible there's no way it
can't be done
no no no
uh-huh-huh no papi right off the bat you
know here huh maybe I should just accept
my fate no I will never get him up my
berry ways will tell me not to oh god
there's no way there is no way my heart
is full of doubt even my champion
bareness can I keep me from committing
bear aside I'm going to embarrass myself
I'm wasting time didn't I just go
through another bear berry bush
no hana haha I don't see any berry
bushes
I see no bird but oh that's ok oh wait I
see fish in that Lake that's uh oh crap
oh no I just went through that berry
berry bush where's the berry he's where
where is it Dignam berries I'm trying
man I'm trying oh god oh no oh god oh
god oh no this might be it for us old
chap
it's my bit for us oh god yeah that's it
for us that's it for us holy ball Reno
how do I eat the Hat
holy crap that's the biggest fish I've
ever seen get get this rock out of the
way oh don't don't get it oh yeah I'm
not losing you
holy crap I thought everything was over
fist
it looks like my luck has changed oh
it's just out of my reach come on oh no
the rocks humongous
I want head I want ha ha ha No
Oh Oh these big damn rocks these
rocks why why Oh Clyde
I'll call pieces of it and feed it into
my mouth does that one fish would feed
me for an eternity oh this is it oh the
shame the shame no this is it least I'll
leave this one Barry maybe just these
small snacks that's you know a reminder
of the joy I had in my life
no no the darkness closes in on me this
is it goodbye friend
game over man I had more fun playing a
video game than I've had in a long time
that was probably the most fun game I've
ever played just cuz it was sorry
goddamn dick ulis hi I'm not playing I'm
not starting this again just got here so
thank you all so much for watching click
the link it is description to play this
game yourself I would recommend it
because it's crazy fun see if you can
beat my high-score get as far as I did
on the first try I've never played it
before by the way so thank you all
someone for watching and as always guys
and as always I will see you in the next
video